قبل بضعه ايام اندلعت الاشتباكات في حلكه
الليل اذ داهم 500 شرطي اسرائيلي ناشطين
فلسطينيين في الضفه الغربيه هناك قانون
للمستوطنين الاسرائيليين وقانون اخر
للفلسطينيين اكثر من 500 شرطي يعملون بشكل
سلمي للتاكد من اخلاء المنطقه في اليوم
الذي سبق اندلاع الاشتباكات هناك كان
الفلسطينيون مشغولون بنصب خيامهم هنا
وعندما قدمت الشرطه لاول مره في هذه
المنطقه المعروفه باي و حصل الناشطون على
سنده تمليك لجزء من الارض ورحب بهم مالك
الاراضي الفلسطينيه المحكمه العليا
الاسرائيليه اصدرت امرا قضائيا يسمح
بانشاء مخيم لبعض الوقت الا انها لم تتعرض
لوضع المعتصمين لذا امر رئيس الوزراء
الشرطه باجلاء ومع مرور الوقت اصدرت
المحكمه العليا قرارا بالامر ذاته وتنوي
اسرائيل انشاء مستوطنه في هذه الارض التي
يقول محللون ان انها يجب ان تكون جزءا من
دوله فلسطينيه في المستقبل من جهتهم يقول
الفلسطينيون ان هذه القرارات تحديدا هي ما
يخشون رؤيته في الحكومات الاسرائيليه
المقبله في السنوات الاربع الماضيه عندما
كان نتنياهو على راس الحكومه كنا نسمع
يوميا عن خطه لانشاء مزيد من المستوطنات
ما اثر على عمليه السلام ولطالما اتهمت
حكومه نتنياهو الفلسطينيين بعدم الرغبه في
المشاركه بعمليه السلام الانتخابات
الاسرائ
تلب المزيد من القلق بالنسبه للفلسطينيين
الذين يعيشون في الضفه الغربيه لانهم
يعلمون بعدم قدرتهم على التصويت وانهم
سيتافون بسياسات الحكومه
الاسرائيليه الا انه يحق لبعض الفلسطينيين
التصويت اذ يمثل العرب 20 في من سكان
اسرائيل حنين زعبي كانت اول سيده فلسطينيه
يتم انتخابها للكنيست الاسرائيلي وهي
تشارك بالحملات الانتخابيه
مجددا تعتبر نفسها دوله يهوديه وليست دوله
لجميع المواطنين فهي تنطلق من مبدا اعطاء
الافضليه لليهود على حساب العرب فيما
يتعلق بالاراضي والميزانيه وحقوق الرعايه
الصحيه
والاقتصاديه وكانت المحكمه الاسرائيليه
العليا قد الغت حظرا من قبل لجنه
الانتخابات يمنع زعبي من الترشح لها الحظر
جاء على اثر مشاركه زعبي قبل ثلاث سنوات
في محاوله كسر الحصار الاسرائيلي على قطاع
غزه والتي تمت على مجموعه من السفن
التركيه وهناك اختلافات حول تفاصيل
الحادثه اذ ان تسعه من القوات الخاصه
الاسرائيليه هبطوا على متن السفينه وقتلوا
تسعه نشطاء بينما يظهر هذا الفيديو تعرض
اعضاء القوات الخاصه للهجوم اثناء العمليه
الا ان النشطاء يزعمون انهم تعرضوا لاطلاق
النار قبل التقاط
الفيديو قالوا بان ارهابيه هم يطلقون هذا
المسمى على كل فلسطيني يناضل من اجل
حقوقه هذا وقد اطلقت مجله فورين بولسي
عليها لقب سيده في اسرائيل الامر الذي
انتقدته زعبي بالانحياز وقالت ان ناخبيها
يثقون بها كصديقه تناضل من اجل حقوقهم في
اجواء سياسيه
قاسيه